Lamar Griffis was 21 ambitious and
adored he was shot and killed in March
in what his family say was a case of
mistaken identity that day feels like
only 59 seconds ago my world Stood Still
um in that moment his mother Monique
spoke to Lamar 20 minutes before he was
killed
he was on his way to visit his
grandmother in Sheffield the shooting
happened as he sat in this car washed
police still don't know who was
responsible but Monique's attention
isn't on why her son was killed but what
leads young people to pick up weapons
we are living in a time where gun and
knife crime
are used as a way of form of
intimidation and for making profit
um
it's unfortunate these young males that
are
drawn towards negative
um social behaviors and criminal
activity
and
this is spelling out where innocent
lives are
being taken like that of nine-year-old
Olivia Pratt Corbell killed in Liverpool
five months after Lamar both innocent
victims caught in crossfire gun-related
deaths are at a nine year high yet all
too often it can be really difficult for
the police to try and encourage people
to come forward with information that
might Aid their investigation
particularly when gang violence is
involved some people are reluctant to be
drawn into perceived danger and it's
this wall of Silence that could prevent
families from getting Justice he was
such a special boy and still is the mom
was always a poser you loved having his
picture taken yeah yeah always smiling
it's this young man's valleys Monique
wants to uphold
he was so driven to be a positive male
and a black male at that in the UK I
would do him in Injustice
if I was to be bitter and angry he would
be telling me Mama
um just keep going her purpose to help
young people choose the right path
one away from the world that robbed her
son of his life
Sky News in Sheffield